Sadiq Khan and starting to ban images of
women in bikinis you'll be in public
signage he's bringing in Sharia law
we've seen this YouTube video it's these
two Muslim guys and they're basically
breaking down and attacking a video I've
done with Infowars talking about the
recent terror attacks Sharia law radical
Islam here's what they had to say
greetings of peace are you guys don't
you know Martin Luther King said that
the greatest danger for Humanity is
sincere ignorance Salam alaykoum how you
guys doing welcome to another episode of
the Dean show dr. bill how you been at
Salaam alaikum alhamdulillah praise be
to Allah I'm doing good but how are you
from doula we made it to another month
of Ramadan now not too long ago we were
in a car we were taking a little ride
and making the best out of the time we
decided to reach out to our friends over
at the Alex Jones Show and we should
call it radical Islam that is what it is
I feel like it's a breath of fresh air
that we're gonna have a president it's
quite frankly not scared to say it what
a class on accept medical Islam it's all
say together llama phobia machine is
affecting even our good friends at the
Alex Jones Show and can you bring people
up to speed what we're kind of talking
about do you remember exactly yes so
Alex Jones uh he did a show about
radical Islamic terrorism and he kept on
blaming Islam not just the Muslims and
he kept on giving examples and his
reasoning is that Muslims are doing act
of terrorism
Islam is responsible and now he's using
the term
a radical Islamic terrorism and we
should call it radical Islam that is
what it is I feel like it's a breath of
fresh air that we're gonna have a
president it's quite frankly not scared
to say it what a class I'm ecstatic with
oh let's all say together llama phobia
machine is affecting even our good
friends at the Alex Jones Show
he's blanketing all of the Muslims and
the faith of Islam saying that you know
Islam is inciting violence so what me
and you what we did was we did a show to
refute his allegations and to show his
double standard and to show to him that
Islam is a faith of peace and unity and
justice that he needs to read the Quran
to get the true picture of Islam in
context you need to read the Quran so
then what happened two days ago three
days ago received a video clip and that
shows that they did a rebuttal to our
response to his show so today inshallah
God willing we are going to provide a
nice wise evidence-based response to him
not to debate him but just to show him
that Islam is the faith of peace it's
wrong for him or anyone to attach
radicalism or terrorism with the
beautiful peaceful fate of Islam there's
not a the see there's a lot of that show
there was a lot of love that went into a
meaning that we were we were we were
coming across not hostile belligerent
you know I'm trying to offend somebody
but you know putting facts in their
place and delivering a message sharing
and giving an invitation and now it's
Ramadan and we're putting in some more
time in love look at that and the Alex
Jones Show they had responded to that
and I don't know which one of the guys
that works with him he was took this
video and you don't see this that same
that same response with the love you see
someone I I would say who's very we go
back to all Akbar Allah Akbar
chanting Allah Akbar
working with radical Islam protecting
the mosque also at the same time we
invited him to you know come on our
program or even you know invite doesn't
have to be me maybe you or any any other
you know reputable scholar of Islam to
kind of someone who's in this area of
expertise and to sit and you know have a
nice discussion so we didn't kind of get
that same thing back but let's go ahead
and cover the the response that his
pride Alex don't show they did towards
what we had put together so we're gonna
go ahead and and let the audience see
this one part and then we'll come back
to it in sharing with them that there is
only one hit love there is no such thing
as a radical Islam of progressive Islam
or liberal Islam there is only one and
there you have it you heard it straight
from his mouth there is only one Islam
so we should just go ahead and drop the
radical part because Islam within itself
what it actually is is radical ideology
and if you actually go look at the
families of Christian families that live
in Iraq say mizzou lotted simply because
they have a different belief a different
faith they are being murdered by Islam
which is a radical ideology there's no
other way around it this guy explained
it so clear there is no progressive
Islam there is no radical Islam there is
only one Islam so I mean he commended
you you said you you you did a great job
of explaining that there's only one
Islam and you should take actually so he
agreed you should take radical out of
Islam because that was the whole point
that there's no such thing as radical
Islam Islam means peace acquired by
submitting to the will of God
so he's but now he's trying to say that
Islam just in itself is a radical
ideology and then he gave you saw what
here he would have sayings as people
being killed in in Iraq or whatnot and
trying to link that back to Islam what
he's saying right you know when I looked
at his response
I cannot connect the dots I cannot
understand his rationale you know we
gave to him with evidence that there is
only one Islam and that Islam is not a
radical it's not Sunni Shia it's a
peaceful Islam it speaks about peace and
justice and what he did was he just took
that term Islam and he said okay that
one Islam is radical Islam it doesn't
make sense so a response to that person
who has done the video so his rationale
is that some Muslims are committing acts
of terrorism they are doing oppression
they are converting minorities in the
name of Allah according to him now if
that is the reasoning for him to label
Islam as radical then with the same
reasoning we could show to him we can
say to him with evidence that Christians
have done and they are also doing now in
the 21st century acts of radicalism acts
of oppression with these children lived
with their parents and a fundamentalist
Christian home for the nine children
like in paradise with anything but we
cover updated their faces because they
are the survivors survivors of a violent
form of discipline practiced by their
parents Kevin and Elizabeth shots the
one face not covered is their
seven-year-old adopted daughter Lydia
she was killed by her parents it pleaded
guilty to killing Lydia and seriously
injuring her eleven-year-old sister's
Araya who almost died
authorities say kevin and elizabeth
shots beat their children regularly
because they believe God wanted them to
forceful conversion and mass shootings
the vast majority of people who are
doing the mass shootings in America not
Muslims at all so exactly the young
white men I turned out that even the
people who are ideologically motivated
you mentioned ideology you are seven
times more likely to be killed by a
right-wing extremist a racist or an
anti-government nutjob seven times more
likely to be killed by that part is that
I am ugh that I all over the world and
here are some examples by the Eddy you
know the army of the the army of the
Lord army of God they are responsible in
the USA for having many many mass
shootings like in abortion clinics in
Planned Parenthood clinics and they have
killed people in the name of Jesus in
the name of Christianity about the Lost
Army in Uganda thousands of innocent
people specially the Muslims have been
slaughtered by Christians in the name of
Christianity
how about the Eastern lightning in China
they believe that Jesus will come back
as a woman and now they are slaughtering
women and children and and people who
are innocent person even a group the
Eastern lightning time to recruit new
members to their Christian cult one
diner refused to give them her number
they beat her within the Christian group
if the Christian God obviously they
don't represent mainstream Christianity
but you're making this disconnecting
this the same way he's trying to take
this fringe you know element Isis and
trying to prompt them up as if they're
representing Islam either usually the
insane State that's what they're usually
using yes of course
they're always misguided people in the
fall in the followers of any ideology
any faith any culture so what that
person is doing is he's taking some
minut minority of the misguided Muslims
for whatever agenda that they are using
the name of Islam and killing innocent
people what we are saying is there are
Christians who have done and they are
doing it now right I mean and rubric
he kills 78 people in Norway in the name
of Christ in the name of Christianity
but we as sane people thinking people
rational people we're not going to blame
Christianity for the acts of the
Christians the misguided Christians so
the same rationale is he or no one else
should use the term radical or the term
terrorists with the beautiful world of
Islam the peaceful Islam and that's what
we kept saying during that car ride that
you you can't take these fringe elements
and have it like as if they represent
the mainstream of for instance you know
the drug cartel and in Mexico or
the some of the other drug cartels that
heavily enforced religious values and
rules that have done horrific I mean
there's places in Mexico that you can't
you cannot actually go towns that you
know the murder rate is it's through the
roof you know when the police doesn't go
there I guess yeah and many of many of
these many of these guys are wearing
crosses you follow me and they would
consider themselves Christian you follow
me but it'd be insane to go ahead and
use this as an example to say that these
people represent a mainstream Christian
that'd be insane but this these
individuals from this day Alex Jones oh
that's what they're actually doing you
know in every continent
you know besides Antarctica I guess
there are Christian groups who are doing
acts of terrorism in the name of Christ
but we are not going to say in a radical
Christian terrorist or radical
Christianity terrorist because that's
not fair we don't want to malign the
faith of Christianity but the acts of
these misguided Christians in the same
way we want to request him to drop the
word radicalism drop the word terrorism
terrorist in associating that with the
word Islam you know that just double
standard because we should use it for
every religion or no religion but why
stop there suppose if an American or a
British or a India and Pakistani commits
acts of terrorism we are not going to
say you know radical Pakistani terrorist
radical American terrorist that does not
make sense but why should we stop there
if you're white person commits act of
terrorism we are not going to say in a
radical a white race a terrorist why
should we stop this if a man commits act
of terrorism are we going to blame all
the men by the way fried radical men
terrorist radical women terrorists a
radical rich terrorist radical poor
terrorist it just becomes insane so the
best thing that we can do is we have to
drop the term radical Islamic terrorists
and we should drop the term radical
Christianity terrorists
and we should blame those individuals
may that be Muslims Hindus use of people
of no faith we should blame them all of
us and before we go to break I think
it's also it's very important for us I
mean if you're trying to have good
relations with your neighbors Muslims
are not going anywhere Christian's
aren't going anywhere we're here on this
earth we need to learn to live together
and especially you know you know people
have to understand this is very
important you don't like just go you're
neighbors next door and you start having
a hostile belligerent attitude with him
and you know how you guys going to live
in peace and harmony it's not going to
work you know I mean so I think that's
really important is for them to drop
this really belligerent hostile attitude
and open the doors of communication but
we had covered in another episode we had
a guest a professor dr. Barnett who's
been on this Alex Channel show and he
has a connection with with them and he's
tried to reach out but he one of his
theories is and many people agree with
this why they're coming after Islam like
this is because it's a big payday you
get there's money to be made
yeah it's a bit sense is business
passion is an ominous you know before
they used to be like 10 or 12
Islamophobic organization now that in
the 90s close to 100 of them and these
people are multimillionaires they get a
lot of grants a lot of support a lot of
sponsors hating Islam became a business
yeah and I think you know good good
hearted people good Christians Jews
whoever's out there you they see through
this and you know the the hostile type
you know people who have that you know
that hate in them I mean we might not be
able to reach them but we can reach
those people who are following actually
because this person would say he's a
Christian but in the words of Jesus you
know one of the greatest commandment is
to love thy neighbor of course is that
what it is condemned thing in Islam by
the way they offered Muhammad peace be
upon him he said and if you eat you're
full and if your neighbors are hungry
you're not a believer you're not a full
believer so we are supposed to look out
for our neighbors not hate them not kill
them not terrorize them but we are
supposed to love them we are supposed to
connect with them you're supposed to
take care of
and that is what Islam is and there's
the message you want to convey to the
world we're gonna take a break we're
right back with more Hannity show don't
go anywhere back here on the D show I
really didn't plan on doing this was
kind of spontaneous so we didn't plan I
didn't plan on doing spending much time
on this but I don't want to just quickly
answer some of these points the the
other points he mentioned when you
mentioned there's only one Islam
submission to the will of the creator
not the creation he said now that there
are Sunni Sufi we'll have this done the
other he named he said okay I got you
here no what would you say
well again I'm going to stand by and
Muslims stand by by the point that there
is only one Islam that was signed by
creator Allah in Arabic so there is only
one Islam that one Islam it's a based
upon the source of the Quran and through
the example of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him so we have the Quran which is
intact we have the Sunnah or the example
of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
which is intact anyone who follows that
we call that person as a Muslim and the
ideology that we follow we say that that
is Islam so if anyone is going to ask me
the question you know Sabae who are you
are you a sunni muslim shia muslim i
would say that i am just a muslim if i
am going to ask from someone will ask me
the question which islam do you follow
the Wahhabi the sufi the sunni shia
i would say i only follow one islam
which is based upon the quran and the
example of mohammed peace be upon him
and that islam speaks about the absolute
oneness of god that islam speaks about
there is only one Quran one version of
the Quran for all the Muslims that Islam
speaks about when we pray what direction
that we follow so all the Muslims we
follow the same direction that one Islam
all muslims are united with that one
islam when we say that muhammad peace be
upon him was no more than a prophet
he was just a man he was a Messenger of
God and that one Islam that all the
Muslims we agree that we believe that
this life is a short life the life of
tests and trial and there would be a day
of resurrection and heaven in hell so
Muslims are united by that one
lomb the one given by muhammad peace be
upon him coming from God
I think the point I think this was also
like a straw man argument this is kind
of diverting what we actually were you
you were making a point over that it was
focusing on Islam cannot be radical
because Islam is actually if you you
want to really get technical you look at
the Lord's Prayer you know everyone
knows that who's a Christian o our
Father we would say our Lord right who
art in heaven hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come thy will be done
so submitting to the will of God right
that's Islam that's what it means it
just it's just in if people would
understand that if you say oh that's
just an Aramaic and that's the language
if you were to equate which language the
Jesus speak it'll be closer to Arabic
Aramaic those are sister languages so
it's just submission to the will of God
so you can't it's totally insane to say
okay peaceful radical submission that
you can't like it doesn't make sense yes
it's a contradictory term you cannot say
in a radical peaceful terrorist right
just a contradiction so Islam is
peaceful
it teaches peace it propagates peace and
there are so many places in the Quran
you know obviously this is a message for
all the viewers especially that person
from the Alex Jones Show that here is
the gold standard which is the Quran and
there are some misguided Muslims who are
going against the main concept the
teachings of the Quran so the Quran
speaks and preaches that humanity should
be united under worship of one God that
we are all made into different nations
and tribes so the Quran says in chapter
49 verse number 13 so God is speaking
and God is saying Allah saying that o
humanity I have created you from one
single male and one single female and
made you into nations and tribes that
you get to know each other not that you
may despise each other you get to know
each other and the best amongst you is
the one who is the most god-fearing
well-mannered person Islam came to unite
humanity Muhammad peace be upon him the
peaceful the anti-racist teachings that
he propagated
he said that an Arab is no superior than
a non Arab in an Arab is no superior
than an Arab a white is not superior
than a black a black is not superior
than a white all of your children of
Adam Adam and Adam was made from dust
that doesn't sound like a radical
teaching a mr. radical is not a teaching
that this unites humanity it's the
teaching that unites humanity it's all
inclusive it is moral and just teachings
the Quran says in chapter 5 verse number
32 they're taking one innocent life is
like taking the life of all of humanity
saving one life is like saving the life
of all the humanity and these are the
teachings of Islam by the ready that the
world needs to know it so we have the
gold standard which is Islam we have the
Quran and then there are always some
misguided people so my message our
message the message from the Muslims is
that just like we don't want to judge
Christianity by KKK we don't want to
judge Judaism by some people who are
doing acts of extremism on innocent
people up there we don't want to judge
Hinduism by some racist Hindus who are
torturing and oppressing the Christians
and Muslims we don't want to judge
Buddhism by some Buddhist monks who are
doing genocide on the Muslims and
minorities in the same way do not judge
Islam but the actions of some misguided
people if you want to judge what Islam
is read the Quran pick up a copy of the
Quran we can send you a free copy of the
Quran call us 800 662 Islam read the
Quran and then you can think of your own
what the Quran is a peaceful book so
that's our message to them
do not judge Islam or any faith by the
actions of a few misguided individuals
he thought I won't spend too much more
time on this well the other part will go
to it let's not say it together how
about we take the advice
of our friend and not offend over 1.7
billion people over the globe and
pulling out these statistics we're going
to dress that knob there we go again
it's 2016 what are we worried about
offending people that night so you know
this is really important you know you
know anybody we have a strong emphasis
in Islam it's very important our
intention what is our intention behind
making the show
what's your intention when you pray when
you're given charity when you're doing
these things the genuine sincere
intention for us doing it is that we're
going to reach some hearts and clear
some misconceptions and deliver this
beautiful message to people who have
gotten caught up in much of the
confusion now we ask these individuals
ask this individual seriously for the
Alex Jones and others you know if you if
you're a truly practicing Christian and
you go by that what's the greatest
commandment to love thy neighbor you
know to me you're trying to make that
you can still critique and talk and
whatnot but when you when it seems like
there's a lot of hate-filled rhetoric
that comes into this and it's not not
working towards a common good a common
goal right so he brings up the next
thing is some of these statistics and
whatnot what do you say about that well
you know first and foremost we have to
redefine the word terrorism terrorism is
anyone who incites terror in innocent
people as simple as that when we take
the definition that means the 404
hundred and six thousand killings by gun
violence in this country every single
one of them is act of terrorism right
and people who are doing the killing out
there you know he's saying that Muslims
are the only ones doing it Muslims don't
have a monopoly we can give a long list
of acts of terrorism now and in the past
by people of different faiths specially
the Christians you know the Liberation
Army of Tripura in India they are
killing innocent people and these are
Christians are doing in the name of
Christianity and they're doing it now
today as we speak and he's saying that
you know Muslims are storming the
hospital offend the schools and killing
butchering you know the eastern
lightning group
in China in the name of Christ they are
storming the schools and killing
innocent children and they have done it
for many many years but you and me we
will not be in Christianity for that
Christianity does not detect neither
does Islam that goes back if you're
being sensible reasonable and what's
your intention if your intention is just
have boost your ratings sensationalism
selective statistics and selective news
reports but that's that's a fact that
you have far more it would be a lot here
what Christians do that every single day
in this country do they blow people up
yes all of the Christians every day
people walk into post off I mean people
walk into post offices they walk into
schools that's what Columbine is I mean
I could do this all day long there's so
there are so many more examples of
Christians I happen to be a Christian
let's back to this notion of you're
idealizing Christianity in my mind to my
read there's so many more examples a
yawn of Christians who do that and you
could ever give me examples of Muslims
we've done it inside this country where
you didn't work they did also did study
there's this poll that Muslims are at
such a lower level of murder rate right
like why there are three percent or
something in the US yeah I mean so this
is totally fabricated it's it's live
what do you say about these statistics
as you bring out most of these things
are in these war zones have been just
bombed in the Stone Age
you're right right you know but even
even even if even if Muslims if this is
true again it's opposite to Islam it's
like even if all I often make this
example if every Muslim was drinking
alcohol right that doesn't wouldn't mean
that Islam allowed it it's not
prohibited same thing if every Muslim
was was doing injustice and harming
innocent people the Islam is free of it
of course of course huh you know so
anyone can build any case but that case
would not be a fear in just case by the
way and you made a really good point
just because some Muslims are using the
word Sharia law or jihad or any Arabic
terminology and doing or committing acts
of violence we have to first and
foremost see what does the Quran says
what does Islam says about it it's law
explicitly prohibits killing of innocent
people no doubt about it even Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him
he said that even in a just war do not
kill the innocent people do not kill the
women and children means non-combatants
so that I also mentioned this that even
if the enemy kills all of the innocent
Muslims or civilians even then Islam
does not give them the right to even
touch harm or kill innocent people from
the enemy side and that's how careful
Islam is so we can go case-by-case and
say okay no this many Muslims have done
this many killing and this many
Christians but that's not the right way
it would be endless game to play the
best thing would be does Islam incite
violence or incites peace every single
verse in Islam in the Quran example of
Muhammad peace be upon him insights
unity insights morality insights justice
and the outcome of justice is peace I
invite him I mean that's the thing I
like what you said and it goes back
what's your intention is it towards
peace then you'll sit with your neighbor
now throw a mic in someone's face or
maybe you got the gun you get in
gangster and whatnot I mean common meat
sit visit the mosque
I mean sincerely genuinely be like look
I don't understand this is what I hear
and sit and let us reason together and
see to put things in their proper
context because if you're you're going
to get what you're looking for
you follow me right you know a really
important point we also need to touch
upon is not to justify violence by some
Muslims but to understand violence by
some Muslims in according to the drone
missile operators they have done the
interview so in news channel than the
interview of them two of them and they
said the drone missile operators they
said that 95 percent our intended
targets we miss it
that means the drones they are falling
on innocent people the women the
children the non-combatants and then
they said on the news channel that now
we wonder how come they are radicalism
extremism terrorism by some Muslims is
it because you are killing their
innocent people by airstrikes and drone
missiles and supporting of the dictator
occupation and all of these things we
need to understand that why are people
angry because anger boils over people
take things in their own hands and they
can use the word Sharia law jihad and
commit and commit acts so we have to if
we are going to tackle radicalism and
terrorism by anyone we have to know the
cause of it and the cause is people are
angry their homes are being destroyed
the family are being killed the land is
being you know sent back to the Stone
Age
and dictators are oppressing them and
there's the reason they're angry at
those foreign powers for supporting all
of those things so if you are going to
tackle terrorism we have to look at the
cause we have to tackle the cause and
once we do justice outcome would be
peace not just in the Middle East but
all over the world and that's the
prescription that Islam provides do
justice with people and that's the way
my dear friend that we need to share
with him so this would be again going
towards Islam doesn't justify doing such
evil acts if someone would take a law
into their own hands and go and kill
innocent people and bombings that's
against but you're talking about now
hey it has to do now with some but this
is a geopolitical thing geopolitical
none of these guy these guys when
they're cutting a head or whoever is
because there's one aspect many because
this show the Alex Jones Show is known
for calling out different events as
being false flags you know reset ups and
whatnot but it's it's interesting it's
selective now for they'll say that for
many other events but now if the guy has
a name that's somewhat Islamic doesn't
know not now here it's like we're not
going to go down a rabbit hole and
exploit it we're going to just say the
Muslims did it you follow me but it's
important that that we know that Islam
is free of it dr. Robert Pape and many
terrorist experts that they don't bring
on their mainstream media platforms
these people also come out these are
academics who substantiate this claim
purely secular because you're seeing
many Muslims suicide terrorist groups
are also pure pure
secular such as the PKK in Turkey the
PKK in Turkey which did numerous suicide
attacks in the 1990s is again a Marxist
read anti religious suicide terrorist
group because you see if Islam is sort
of a radical religion or if it were just
radical Muslims doing this then what you
would expect is sort of this thin veneer
of suicide attack kind of scattered all
around the world you would expect that
oh there's 1.4 billion Muslims you know
there's this teeny tiny fringe of
Muslims kind of everywhere who'd be
willing to do suicide attack but that's
not the way the data looks it's really
concentrated and it's really
concentrated in occupation this is has
to do with foreign invasions yeah I mean
so it's same person listening to the
show they have to think you know very
well the acts of terrorism radicalism in
the Middle East 60 70 90 hundred years
ago it was a peaceful cease when
oppression and the dictators and the
colonial powers and they do in the
European powers when they came and they
occupied and oppressed and left the
dictators that's how people became angry
you know how comes you guys are
oppressing us and killing our innocent
people it's a human problem whenever
there is oppression on human beings
people act and take the things in their
own hand
even though Islam condemns anyone taking
things in their own hand and killing
innocent people
Islam condemns it and when when you when
you when you add up all the amount of
bombs that have been dropped on on these
Muslim majority countries they're
they're not in the hundreds they're in
the thousands nobody dropped a bomb here
there's thousands of thousands and I
displacement people are becoming
refugees making refugees go back home
what stop bombing my home you know the
mean people are eager for you what's
going on I mean so this is the root
cause let's look at the root cause and
then we'll understand the problem you
find you know a good example is in 1942
or 41 right the Pearl Harbor in the
1940s oh you must become angry Japanese
attack the Pearl Harbor and killed the
soldiers what did we do out of anger to
reply to the cause cause and effect is
always there the US government when went
there Hiroshima Nagasaki two bombs were
drop close to 300 thousand people died
innocent people right bombs were dropped
right on the civilians Center so it's
really important for us there's always a
cause and effect if we see that there is
a problem we have to understand what's
the cause of the problem the cause of
the problem is not Islam it is
geopolitical once we take care of that
inshallah God willing there would be
justice there would be unity and there
would be peace so that's our intention
really to reach out to people from this
allergy on show and any other networks
out there people sit with the Muslims
talk with the most let's have some some
civil conversations and and and really
try to work together for a common good
let's just touch upon Ramadan it is here
it's it's made it and and this is part
of the Dawa you know communicating this
peaceful beautiful message of
submissions that are created not the
creation living your true purpose that
was sent by the Creator Islam is nothing
esoteric just only a few can understand
it really makes sense and if you're
asking God Almighty for guidance you'll
see that Islam provides beautiful
teachings preserved authentic and what
would you comment on as many Muslims
procrastinate throughout the year even
and now of living it and communicating
this beautiful message of peace well
what is the very first thing comes to
your mind by the Eddy if I say the word
Ramadan would that be food I would that
be fasting French during fasting right
maybe not food hopefully for some people
so it's very important Ramadan its
fasting but even before fasting was
prescribed in the year 624 Ramadan was
the month of the Quran it's a month of
the Quran in Ramadan the Quran was
revealed in the starting in the year 610
and it says in the Quran chapter number
2 verse number 185 that Quran came as a
guidance for all of humanity
and who is to take that guidance that
beautiful message the message of peace
and justice to the world we Muslims are
given that assignment we are supposed to
be the ambassador's of taking the
guidance so it's really important when
we are going about in fasting and waking
up for CIFOR and doing iftar and
planning the whole day and Avada in the
end atharva prayer we also have to be
conscious that this Quran that we have
it is meant not just for Arabs Indian
Pakistani African it is meant for all of
humanity so that means we should be
actively conveying the message so here
are some of the ways we can really
quickly do it we can give them our
colleagues so if you make this aramid on
cars by the way this is a greeting card
to be given toward non-muslim neighbors
and colleagues and Friends if they open
it it has a wonderful message about what
Ramadan is number one number two is
really important for us also to mention
to our friends specially the Christians
and the Jewish friends that when we are
fasting or actually fasting because the
previous prophets they also used to fast
chapter number two verse number 183 says
the God is saying that fasting is
prescribed to you means to the Muslims
as it was prescribed to those before you
that you may not be in God consciousness
taqwa so we are fasting because Jesus
and Moses and Abraham and Noah peace be
upon all of them they also used to fast
you know when he received the Ten
Commandments Moses peace be upon him it
says in the book of Exodus as he was in
the state of fasting Jesus fasted
Matthew chapter 4 verse number 2 he was
fasting the way he that he fasted is the
way that Muslims are fasting now John
discerning he just did not used to
refrain from orange juice or from fish
burger right he used to fast total
abstinence from food water drink
anything else so we are fasting because
we are following the rituals of all the
prophets we are we are also following
the message of all the prophets the
message of absolute submission to one
God alone not worshipping humans and
idols or the creation but only worship
the Creator we can also have open houses
open the doors of the most mosque
Mercedes
invite people for the iftar open houses
socialize with them connect with them
give them the date fruit and the samosas
connect with them and introduce them the
beautiful fate of Islam invite our
neighbor saw homes
Ivica alex jones and his crew come uh
yeah they're like samosas and very Ani
welcome no seriously we do want them to
come by the way so they can sit down
with us as brothers and sisters in
humanity we want them to come now you
know Ramadan is coming now in the month
off in the season of summer that means
long days and especially the families
and the kids are off we can take this
opportunity and go outside in downtown
busy places and pass on the brochures we
can also have many Dawa tables you know
so many carnivals and festivals are
going on like recently last weekend in
Skokie we had the Skokie festival of
cultures gain peace I had a dollar boot
up there along with the MCC much it this
year many more people came compared to
previous years because people want to
learn about Islam there is so much buzz
in the media about Islam and people want
to know what Islam is so these are some
of the ways that we as Muslim
besides doing fasting besides reading
the Quran and the long prayers at night
also we have to realize that this is the
month of the Quran Quran is meant for
all of humanity let's take the message
to humanity Sean that's beautiful
beautiful that you can't go wrong there
connect educate yourself to ways to be
fooled is by believing something is not
true or refusing pushing away not
wanting to building up a wall to not let
what is true come to you and great
opportunity is to visit a mosque sit
with the Muslims those places of worship
or not bomb-making factories come inside
look inside there fede making factories
please make a Sami people inside who are
dedicating their lives to the service of
the Creator the heavens are the same
creator that created Jesus the one that
Jesus pray to call people to worship
that's the Creator we're worshiping the
one God worship Him alone not his
creation delivering this message to you
that's our intention to unify to bring
some love more love to you guys we
dedicated the car ride
and most of the show we didn't I didn't
plan on doing the whole episode but
almost over 80 90 percent was I hope
that this doesn't go in vain I hope the
people will really look at you know our
genuine attempt to clear message much
much of this misinformation and
hopefully the invitation will be
accepted thank you very much
Salam alaikum did I sell that and that's
that piece for greeting we started with
peace we end with peace Salam alaikum in
the words of Jesus how would he say it
Chanel Malik yes I still am I did come
peace be with you thank you very much